thank you
[Music]
we haven't talked about the Russia
Ukraine situation in a second there's a
new one it's been going on dude what's
going on but does everybody remember the
two Brits that were sentenced to death
in Russia when they were fighting in
Ukraine no what happened so there were
two British uh fighters who went to
fight in Ukraine to Aid Ukraine like
boxer Fighters no like like uh like
soldiers oh soldiers okay yeah for the
war they went to go like rep for Ukraine
because boxing's gonna it's gonna get
you killed with against a tank man
you can't just [ __ ] be like a hey
comes out the gloves let's go they're
like are you ready and they're like
you're right about that that might be a
little scary to see though as a soldier
imagine this [ __ ] on your scope
and you see a guy just go come on yeah
you just blast them we're going this way
now damn if I saw McGregor I just
dropped my rifle and be like can I get
an autograph you take a picture yeah so
yeah these two British soldiers
uh went to Ukraine and they were
captured by Russian forces in Ukraine
and then they were sentenced to death
those two have now escaped yo what do
you think they did I it doesn't say how
did they do it so so this is like
actually very very well they're caught
in Ukraine or Russia they were caught in
Ukraine by Russian troops oh I see I see
yeah okay
they have escaped and they are now
returning to their families they were
recently they recently filmed the clip
on an airplane uh about their return but
it's very very little information
because it basically says they have to
like debrief and oh yeah yeah they can't
do anything press related or anything
bad ass dude yeah so there's there's
literally no crazy details and just so
everybody knows uh the two soldiers are
a guy named Aiden Aslin age 28 from
Nottinghamshire and Sean Penner aged 48
from bedfordshire that's a that's a
different age cap that's a big that's
like Father and Son here we go let's
watch this little video right here as
they're on an airplane on their way back
home
University
not just us there was also in total 10
phones that were in captivity
um we're going to be pretty quiet in
regards to Media stuff until we get
things sorted out and whatever we just
want everyone to know the good news Etc
so thanks to everyone that's been
supporting us and yeah so it's really
much we appreciated
wow they'll be able to say some [ __ ]
that they saw in there for sure yeah so
just give a just a highlight a couple of
things you said he literally said things
like you know we're now out of the
danger zone and then his other homie was
like by the skin of our teeth we don't
know any more details in that they also
said that they weren't the only ones
there were also 10 other foreigners that
were in captivity so they all just
escaped they all escaped yeah they all
stayed there was a group efforts dang
dude yeah somebody's already like
bidding on those movie oh for sure
that's immediately [ __ ] Peter Burgers
I bet yeah it says 10 10 other
foreigners that were in captivity might
be like a Michael Bay film or some [ __ ]
I wonder how they yeah Mark Wahlberg has
signed on I need to know
yeah so they just said we just want to
let everyone know the good news so
thanks to everyone who's been supportive
of us it's really much appreciated thank
you to everyone and the two British
Fighters were captured while battling
Kremlin troops in the Ukrainian city of
Mario pole amid Russia's invasion of the
Eastern European country they were
forced to surrender their position
alongside Ukrainian troops back in April
whoa back in April it's now September
when they were intercepted by Russian
forces
it's been going on for a minute Gundy or
Johnny online and his friends have been
running his social media accounts to
keep people updated on the situation as
it unfolded and they were put on trial
and the Russian held eastern Ukraine and
were sentenced to death in June for
mercenary charges
other overseas fighters who went on
trial and have since been released
include Brits John Harding Andrew Hill
and Dylan Healy as well as some other
name that I can't [ __ ] pronounce from
Croatia and other Swedish troops and
stuff like that how that works mercenary
charges like
um I don't know I mean I do know that
there's a lot of countries higher
mercenaries because a lot of countries
have short troop shortages
but the country that you fight for or
the purpose or initiative that you're
fighting for still has to fall in line
with the laws of whatever that country
is and there's all these like Rules of
Engagement so for example like
um there might be a war going on between
these two countries and then there might
be a neutral country that's like well we
have a oil factory there and we just
need to get whatever those things out so
they'll hire their own mercenaries to go
protect it and so they're technically
not fighting for each side they're just
providing for security so there's that
kind of situation but there's also
situations where a lot of countries will
be like oh we need to do some dirt like
assassinate a [ __ ] over there I
don't want if anything goes bad the
press to come back on our country we'll
hire another guy to go do it I mean war
is just a dirty game you know
crazy I remember Ukraine was like Hey if
you guys want to fight for Ukraine and
you're from a different country come on
over uh you can volunteer
got me to click we'll pay you in Bitcoin
or whatever
come on and then a lot of people were
signing up they're like we're gonna go
not only am I gonna put the Ukrainian
flag on my Twitter account I'm gonna
actually go out there and fight some
people did that you know come meet me at
the quad if you want to go and fight
with me
not to be super uh skeptic but like uh
are there ever you know I'm sure there
are but you know like tactical reasons
for like letting somebody Escape or you
know oh yeah for sure yeah wow Anthony
the the way like war is it's any game
that can be played that you're thinking
is being played at the same time and
could be so you just don't know there's
always a counter-operative yeah there's
a counter to the counter to the counter
that you're not even understand you know
like you just how did you did you ever
get like trained for like that type of
[ __ ] no
a fake Korean man
no dude
I just know of some people and then from
the stories that I hear of some people
I'm like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy
what stories have you heard so some
people that are like in Special
Operations like born identity type [ __ ]
like they're going into countries with
fake passports you know there's like
that that's normal that happens there's
people that are like I think there's
like three levels of like
um I think Rules of Engagement like like
Special Operations where like for
example we're trying to kill Bin Laden
those [ __ ] know we're coming
our [ __ ] know we're coming but
no one knows who they are that's like
level one so they just get set over but
everyone knows okay we're gonna go over
there the neighboring countries all know
so if you see [ __ ] plane going
through this guys okay America is doing
its thing then at the far end there is
no one knows you're going no one on that
side even knows you're receiving you and
your uh identity is completely different
you're gonna go there through the
contacts that you've made in the last
decade in that country you're gonna
assemble your own militia assemble your
own uh weapons have your own operation
Rambo like that kind of [ __ ] so
everything looks like it's very in-house
or off the Record types yeah and then no
one's here to save you yeah and you're a
journalist there or something and if you
get caught you're like you can't claim
uh [ __ ] that you're from like America
I would have I pulled out my American
password you know have you read that
section were they there it's it makes
you feel like you're very protected but
then the government's like no they went
wrong we don't claim them [ __ ] like that
right I would have done that times out
at the very end I'll be like hold on
hold on hold on hold on actually I'm
American look at my passport time's out
interfere outfit they wouldn't believe
you they will believe me because like
the conflicts were not supposed to be in
we're in you know and then so that's
when they need to use that variation of
play so that way like wait what the [ __ ]
America's not even supposed to be here I
thought there's some sort of treaty or
some sort of agreement why is America
here to have to send it in that way did
you know they just found some um Russian
spies in Hawaii they've been living as
like
you know people that came there in the
70s or 80s or something like a couple
it's a it's a married couple that was
orchestrated by Russia they took over
identities
um of a Texan couple that died or
something
and then yeah so they've been here in
America for like a long long time and
then they've been living in Hawaii and
um I think it was the FBI or CIA they
found them and in all their neighbors
like what the hell like they're just
they just been here for decades and and
they're like they've been chill
so it's like these they express like
what they were doing were they just
selling like uh sending back Intel or
most spy [ __ ] is Intel it's just Intel
right they they just uh what do you call
it they just caught them so they haven't
really disclosed what it was but I just
thought that was crazy like your
neighbor could be a spy like where do
you go out to do you go straight to like
[ __ ] torture to get the info out on
like what you did like you know what I
mean like for for Espionage like because
like if it's not like a hard drive that
it's like [ __ ] up here right so you
go straight to like Guantanamo Bay and
they just extract that [ __ ] with any
means necessary like is that just the
protocol for America and they don't want
to
they know they want to know like who the
like when they pull the thread like
what's the actual rug you know so they
don't want to just like snip the the
thread and like [ __ ] we lost the lead at
all yeah they want to know what the [ __ ]
like what's the entire organization
that's why we can't just beat these old
people Francis they gotta like pull a
fingernail first yeah yeah yeah because
you got like 20 nails and you have to
translate because they probably speak
perfect pigeon
Korean translator on Deck hey jailbrokes
foreign